[Música]
y hablamos de salud en directo américa
de france a 24 para llegar estar conmigo
en el estudio más romeros a la mar
bienvenida feliz viernes ya a nuestro
último programa del año y por ello
hacemos un resumen no termina 2021 y el
momento de hacer el balance de lo que
fue todo este año el segundo año de
pandemia por cierto le pregunto entonces
queremos destacar si ya llevamos un
tiempo en este en este cuento entonces
toca un poco ver que hemos aprendido qué
cosas hemos hecho bien y también qué
cosas hemos hecho mal 2021 ha sido
innegablemente el año de las vacunas no
para empezar se han implementado
campañas de vacunación en todo el mundo
que hacen ahora mismo que más de la
mitad de la población mundial tenga más
de al menos una dosis de las vacunas ya
inoculada y eso es un hito histórico que
no podemos negar nunca antes había
pasado algo así con esta celeridad pero
sabemos que esas cifras también esconden
desigualdad del 55 por ciento de la
población mundial ahora mismo cuenta con
una dosis suramérica y ya supera el 70
por ciento de su población parcialmente
o totalmente inmunizada pero no podemos
olvidar que detrás de este 70% no es lo
mismo chile que haití donde por ejemplo
en haití no ha empezado práctica la
campaña de vacunación y esa es la gran
deuda que nos queda del año 2021 también
el gran fallo desde mi perspectiva
porque pues podemos ver como hemos
venido repitiendo que por ejemplo en
áfrica sólo el 11% de la población tiene
al menos una dosis de la vacuna pero más
allá de estas cifras y más allá de esas
desigualdades que ahora volveremos a
hablar hemos descubierto muchísimas
cosas también sobre la vacuna no para
empezar hemos visto cómo hay una pérdida
relativa de la inmunidad con los meses
que avanza hemos podido empezar a poner
ya los detalles sobre cómo sucede eso
han empezado los debates también
alrededor de las campañas de dosis de
refuerzo con sus debates tanto
científicos como éticos y también hemos
confirmado que las vacunas son seguras
esas personas que en diciembre 2020
decían que no sabían que querían esperar
un tiempo a ver cómo se había efectos
secundarios lo que pasaba ahora ya
llevamos un año de vacunas y podemos
confirmar que efectivamente son seguras
y que funcionan marc y también hemos
aprendido muchas cosas le pregunto
entonces con qué nos vamos a quedar este
2021 pues a mí me gustaría destacar una
reflexión que nos daba a maría fernanda
gutiérrez de las biólogas de la
universidad javeriana de colombia y
explicaba muy con que nos podemos quedar
este 2021 escuchemos la preview de cómo
funcionan las vacunas cuando por qué no
se mostró poner una dosis otra dosis
aprendimos de varias clases todo está en
la vacunación nos enseñó muchísimo sobre
los principios básicos de la inmunología
que aprendimos a hablar de los
anticuerpos aprendimos a hablar de los
antígenos sobre ninguna hablar de las
pruebas rápidas es decir aprendimos de
microbiología lo que no hemos aprendido
en la vida a mí me parece que eso nos
ayuda a fortalecer una cosa que yo
considero que en nuestros países en
américa latina tiene muy débil que es la
cultura científica claro por ejemplo
raúl nunca nos hemos preguntado qué es
un ibuprofeno porque nos lo tomamos
cuando tenemos dolor no el conocimiento
científico al final es una cosa muy
estanca que no siempre es accesible a
toda la población en general y habernos
hecho todas estas preguntas de haber
tenido incluso una cierta desconfianza
al final nos ha permitido acceder a un
conocimiento que nos permite también ser
más críticos con las decisiones de salud
pública de nuestros gobiernos de las
farmacéuticas nos permite tomar
decisiones informadas y no sólo de las
vacunas también sobre cómo se transmite
el virus
y 2021 es el año en que deje de
desinfectar como una loca toda la fruta
y toda la verdura que llegaba a mi casa
porque sabemos que al final eso ya no
era efectivo entonces pues todas esas
cosas toda esa cultura científica que
nos ha quedado nos va a servir también
para 2022 bueno hablemos del futuro 2022
será el fin del año del fin de la
pandemia el próximo año marc la ponga en
aprietos pues esperemos que sí es una
pregunta que todavía no podemos
responder en este momento pero sobre
todo si queremos que 2022 sea el año que
podamos poner fin a esta crisis
sanitaria y que también el virus del
cómic 19 se vuelvan endémico y deje de
ser una crisis de salud pública van a
ser claves dos cosas por un lado las
vacunas ahora volveremos a hablar de
ellas y dos los tratamientos antivirales
que han aparecido en los últimos meses
de 2021 empecemos por estos tratamientos
recordemos que hay dos pastillas
bastante prometedoras de merck y de
facer que sirven para tratar la
enfermedad y evitar que el kobe 19
desarrolle en un cuadro grave entonces
pueda hablar a muchos de nosotros por
ejemplo cómo se distribuyen no si
volveremos a cometer los mismos errores
o no que con las vacunas vamos a repasar
las cifras de esas ventas que ya están
sucediendo tanto con la pastilla de met
como con la pastilla de facer por
ejemplo la pastilla de merck tiene
aseguradas ya siete millones y medio de
tratamientos comprados y eso supone tres
cuartos del total de lo que pueden
producir en este año 2021 en los lado de
ese día son casi 12 millones de
tratamientos que tienen ya acuerdos de
compra y eso es prácticamente el 15 por
ciento de todo lo que van a producir en
2022 en el año que viene como no cabe y
como cabía esperar los eeuu desde el
país que ha comprado más de ambas
pastillas entonces vemos que empieza a
ver un acaparamiento un poco también de
este recurso ojalá no pase como con las
vacunas ojalá que no mar y entonces le
preguntó que si debe pasar con la
vacunación para poder salir de esta
crisis sanitaria pues lo hemos repetido
muchísimas veces lo principal es
terminar con esas desigualdades en las
campañas y en el acceso a los fármacos y
para que eso pase hay mucha gente por
ejemplo que pide que las farmacéuticas
liberen las patentes para que estas
vacunas se puedan producir a gran escala
escuchemos lo que nos decía maría
fernanda gutiérrez al respecto
en este momento esas casas farmacéuticas
tienen el poder y eso lo representa
ellos mucha mucha plata y obviamente
como una industria que está hecha cuya
misión es producir plata pues no van a
querer liberar las patentes por el otro
lado es un problema importantísimo
social
es decir es un problema de salud es un
problema social deberían poderlas
liberar para que la ex para que otras
casas tan auténticas puedan trabajar y
tuviéramos mucho más acceso a las
vacunas y mucho más económicas y mucho
más rápidas y sin tantos problemas
instante esperas
ojalá los países que más lo necesiten
dejen de esperar estas vacunas se ve
difícil que ocurra pero ojalá sea la
buena noticia de 2022 ojalá amar buenas
noticias para este año que viene 2022
gracias ha sido un placer también
compartir con usted por todo este año
hablando de nuestra salud nos vemos
grande covián en 2022 y bueno con mi
hijo nuestro productor buena salud para
usted para 3